So we knew from day one when we launched
the service we were going to charge,
so there was going to be
paid plans on the service.
We saw no reason why we should
start off with a free plan.
We were like, this is going to be
a business that makes money, and
in 2006 that was not vogue at the time.
Quite honestly a lot of people
were like, build it for free,
get a bunch of users, and
figure out how to monetize later.
And we were just like, I don't know.
It seems like we can monetize right now.
Why don't we go ahead and
start that and then we don't have
to worry about the weirdness of?
Like, it's easier to give more stuff for
free than than it is to start
charging stuff for later on.
It's the way we thought about it.
And so, when we did YC, we had not
written any lines of code, and
we started in the January of 2006.
And that's when we first started
writing and programming WuFu.
And then we had an interface prototype
in February, so in about a month.
And that interface prototype
allows you to see how a new way of
building forms and designing them,
but it didn't hook up to a database,
you couldn't save it,
you couldn't collect information.
But it allowed people to see, like
this is a better way of doing things,
better than what you would see,
say, from Microsoft InfoPath or
other form builders out there.
And we said like we should ship this.
Right, like see what people say,
basically do that step of talking users,
getting engagement, and
get people excited about it.
And so
we released an interface preview demo.
And that demo, at the end of it you
create and design the form, and
when you hit the save,
it says thanks for trying out the demo.
When you want to know when we finally
launch, give us your email address.
And we got over 100,000 people
to go through that demo, so
that when we'd launch we'd be able
to start off up front off of it.
But, the thing is, part of that idea
also, again, came from Joe Kraus
surprisingly at the time, where he
talks about like a lot of companies,
what they don't realize is that they
should not just beta test their product,
but beta test their pricing.
Right, their paid upgrade and
conversion triggers.
And you're never going to know that
until you finally put a price up there
and put a button that says you
can't do this until you pay.
And so like a lot of that
just resonated with us.
We were like, this company needs to be
something that stands on its own, and
I guess you could say we were the kind
of founders that didn't have the risk
profile that, say, like, we're going to
take the risk on like, giving tons of
things for free, try to figure out how
to scale, and eventually monetize.
To us, it was like, this is either
going to be something people pay for,
or it's not.
And I think for 99% of BDB sort of
companies and services, it's easy to do.
I think I meet a lot of founders
who think I'm building something,
it's better than the competition,
it's easier to use, it's faster, and
then I'm going to charge a whole lot
less for it, and I think that's usually
a mistake that people have, or I'm just
going to give it all away for free.
That's just like, that's where you're
losing out on a lot of opportunity and
economics for stuff.